what's up reject nation we got mics this
time a better quality audio for this
specific video if you guys haven't seen
yet we did do a reaction to the Justice
League announcement I didn't know when
it was gonna happen just you guys should
go check that video out because my heart
rate has calmed down my headache is
slowly going away the intense hyper
focus mode is dissipating because I was
very late to learning the news about
when the stream was gonna be I was
hearing all this chatter
obviously like everyone else about Zack
Snyder meeting with AT&T and blah blah
blah I welcomed by like 8:00 this
morning and then I was like let me let
me just see when this stream was
supposed to be because hearing word that
he might announce it right I was like oh
crap it's today yeah early I go the
screams happening right now on the vo
what the hell is this I download the V
rap and I just put my headphones on I
was listening to the whole time I texted
John I was like dude can you come over
said like 10:30 because the movie should
end around that time and so I was listen
I listened to the whole thing it was
actually a really great commentary I
don't the movie well enough to not have
to feel like have to watch along pay
attention it was just some audio track
it was really exciting stuff we had the
the camera was ready to go and there
sure enough it's like a fan asked him
and I thought it was so beautiful
because I'm like you could feel it
coming because it burst he's misleading
the fan asked when's the center cook
coming and then he answered it in a way
that was I don't know let me just play
the footage for you don't cut the stream
the Sun I've been very clear with what I
did with it you know it's not really
it's not really it's only up to me per
se if it was up to me I would have
probably already like left it on a thumb
drive in a bathroom somewhere so then
when he answered it that way man is it
not actually gonna happen they need to
do he did the thing with his glasses the
reflection we taught her added on her a
computer I was like what did you see
what was that what was
like wine that zoom in enhanced is
really exciting stuff immediately the
second he announced it notification went
off on our Gmail HBO max releasing it it
was it was all obviously very timed
right and then Hollywood Reporter put
out this article that I thought would be
fun to go through and breakdown to John
found that was pretty much breaking down
the plans for the actual cut in and of
itself and there's some really good
information in here it's not really
gonna go through like the scenes that
weren't in the movie per se but pretty
much the process and how this got made
what their plans are gonna be and why
they decided to go down this streaming
service path there's a lot of really
great stuff in here will link the
original article in the description box
probably at the end talk a little bit
about that Ruby Rose stuff I'll be short
this is like the main entree of this
platter today oh yeah I just want to say
up front I saw comments coming in on
that video of people being like oh the
money can buy anything of course you
guys want it now and I put the center a
community page in Twitter we did a video
at November 23rd 2017 that was going
through the petition the first petition
that went around for releasing the
snider it could title of the video had
should we sign it went through the whole
petition you could see me getting
persuaded and and I was like yeah I want
this Snyder cut I flat out put it out
there in the ether for everyone to see
that I'm on the train for releasing the
Snyder code since November 2017 I was
one of the people who did enjoy who did
really like the version of Joss Whedon's
that did come out I acknowledge that I
really like it because it's just a
really fun movie it could see kind of
the Saturday morning cartoon they were
going for that being said that does not
mean that I have not been one of the
people who have been championing to have
this movie come out as well well I think
the excitement too isn't just us going
it's gonna be great because you know it
could end up any which way but it's the
excitement of the fact that this is a
moment like the studio's have literally
acknowledged what everyone has been
shouting for for so long and it's a
pretty big and pretty fascinating thing
see actually happened you know it's it's
crazy I mean like Sonic the Hedgehog was
the first movie that had this like
movement occur how fans really impacted
yeah
and this is something that could have
easily died we're always seeing
petitions come out for replace this
director or do this do that me shoot all
Game of Thrones and this has been
something that fans have been really
hardcore championing for four years now
years and to see it fulfilled whether
this movie's good or not it's just
awesome that it's coming out first
kooky as everything's been with the DC
EU it is another development where
you're like okay interesting yeah you
know it's it is a creative choice which
I do appreciate it might not be a movie
exactly the article will go into but hey
let's go into this article okay so here
the morning after was their agent saying
that Toby Emmerich chairman of Warner
Brothers pictures was acknowledging the
movement and more importantly was
willing to exceed this is real people
wanted would you guys ever consider
doing something was what Emmerich was
asking months ago I think I heard it
from Grace Randolph run behind the
trailer first Toby Emmerich was the one
who was mainly championing to have this
done for as much crap as executives get
here's what Zack Snyder said about it it
will be an entirely new thing and
especially talking to those who have
seen the release movie a new experience
apart from the movie I'm glad he's
saying that because I went through the
first like hundred comments on our video
of course there's a lot of people who
are saying how different can it really
be for those who haven't been really
following the leaked details of what was
cut out of that version for him to
acknowledge this is important because
this will be a very different experience
and then he goes on to say you probably
saw one fourth of what I did so for
anyone who's asking about how different
can this be Joss Whedon did reshoots and
and did different scenes and he also cut
out a [ __ ] ton of stuff for him to say
one fourth let's put in a different
perspective that's 3/4 of a film that
were not featured in there a lot of like
75% of a movie and I'm also sitting here
going is that 1/4 of the two-hour cut
down you turned in because that could
mean that there's even more with the
original cut being like four hours
exactly the article goes on to say
before Emory came calling at Schneider I
always thought it was a thing that in 20
years maybe somebody would do a
documentary and I could lend them the
footage little snippets of a cut known
has ever seen kind of like the death of
Superman yeah
produce documentary by Jon Schnepp
that's what I thought because I remember
signing that petition and still thinking
it's probably not going to happen even
though I'm hoping it'll happen yeah I
think it was the only movie petition
I've ever actually signed is gonna say
usually those draw your ire I didn't
think could actually happen I thought we
would get a documentary and I still feel
like there will be a documentary about
this yeah now it's gonna be everything
now is gonna be the complete package of
cuts I mean if it ends in let's say
worst case and ends are coming out in
pain like disappointing for people it'll
even make for a better document it'll
yeah that'll get made in 20 I'm hoping
it's great you know I'm putting my faith
out there you know after everything I've
heard about it yeah adds Deborah Snyder
with the new platform and streaming
services you could have something like
this you can't release something like
this theatrically but you could with a
streaming service it's an opportunity
that wasn't there two years ago to be
honest I mean that's a great point like
with HBO max being announced honestly I
don't know anyone who's really been
excited for HBO max well yeah everyone's
just going why do I need this one I
already have X amount of other things
you know and then whatever new promos
are putting out for the service it's not
exciting anyone this is evidently the
first thing to excite people the fact
that this was like a four hour cut
originally and he was trying to get it
down to two and a half hour or something
like that they aren't going to later
yeah a streaming service would be the
ideal platform to release this on
especially because you do have your DC e
eu whatever the hell the universe is
called now you do have that Universal
the Warner Brothers universe of DC
actors you have that going it's doing
its thing and then you have their
standalone stuff like Joker to create
less confusion and to make this easier
for people to latch on to putting it on
a different platform that is still
accessible for the world this is a
streaming service is the best bet more
than a blu-ray release yeah in January
2017 he had what he considered his
optimal version of Justice League almost
four hours long although he knew it was
something the studio wouldn't release
Warner's wanted to cut in the two-hour
rage he delivered a rough version with
an approximate two hour 20 minute run
time that was the first cut the studio
saw both sides agree that there was much
work still to be done before the
November release but tragedy struck the
Snider's with their daughter autumn died
by suicide mr. rest in peace a month and
a half later Zach officially stepped
away and Whedon was brought in the one
part in that article that especially
with the fact that Warner Brothers seems
to have worked this out because there is
always the you know the rumor the
conspiracy whatever you want to call it
I use that as an excuse to fire Zack
Snyder you know that was a big thing
though what's going around it seems like
what the press releases that are going
making them I mean obviously Hollywood
Reporter had this article ready to drop
you know right when that announcement
happen instantly a thick article this is
at least the story that they're still
sticking with and so I'm just gonna take
it as truth he did have to go because
you know he had to grieve for his
daughter and that and I mean they go on
in the article to touch on that more
right
I can't imagine some kind of true
conspiracy being that ya know like give
them exactly yeah I mean in a situation
like that I wouldn't want the guy to be
making the movie yeah I I hate when
people make conspiracies about things
like that especially article goes on to
say forgive that the version that fans
wanted technically didn't exist what did
exist was a semi unfinished work with no
visual effects no post-production one
person who adjusting that version
described it like a car with no panels
just a drivetrain of some seats and it
said on a hard drive in the Snider's
house when we left the movie I just took
the drive of the cut on it I honestly
never thought it would be anything there
is a documentary waiting to be made even
this story it does feel like an actual
like you feel like you're watching a
real-life little movie about a filmmaker
just trying to get his dream you know
like you've seen that movie before and
yeah little things like that like what
if he didn't take the drive still be
happening I mean and to have such a
tragedy happen but to have the fan
support and then think like this dream
of building to this Justice League movie
something that he's been very passionate
about combusted many many years into
making and developing like to get to
that point there's an inspiration to
this let's hope the movies really good
it was on the two year anniversary
however that the zenith hit and the hash
I became a top worldwide trend hash
Tagg release the cider cut is the most
tweeted hashtag about a movie that WB
has ever made but it's a movie that
never released
it's a weird stat but it's cool that
that is pretty sweet
yeah because he wasn't on he wasn't like
instantly coming out no ask him for it I
don't there's nothing in this article
that hints at he had to sign something
to not talk about it feels very
grassroots in an in an odd way yes like
the fans picked up the ball and then ran
with it and then he was like oh damn
well okay I guess I'm gonna watch the
game then I mean it was a long time
before Zack Snyder really started
chiming and going yeah we should try to
do this
yeah it wasn't instant you know and I
think that's cool because of that and
the level of momentum and passion that
drove him to participate in the release
the Snyder after that Saturday morning
phone call the Snyder's began to move
puzzle pieces into place we had to
figure out what it meant to finish it
and how do you pull it off recalls
Deborah who was in the via livestream
towards the end the Snyder's put
together a presentation in an early
February invited a select group of
executives from Warner Brothers HBO Max
and DC to their house in Pasadena to
screen Zac's a little scene version that
was shown in black and white we're going
to Pasadena all the images have been in
black like black and white obviously
there's a black and white cut I would
love to watch a black or white cut
actually that gets me excited the number
of executives in the room there were
more than a dozen attendants ranging
from Warner's Emmerich Caroline
Blackwood Walter Hamada and Courtney
Valenti I don't know half of them HBO's
max Kevin Riley Sarah Aubrey and Sarah
2e to DC's Jim Lee I know DC's Jim Lee I
don't know the former three they're good
friends of mine share the importance of
the potentially extensive undertaking
heads of physical production and
business affairs were there to assess
what needed to be done and how much it
would cost at his presentation after the
screening Snyder outline ideas for not
just releasing the cut but the concept
of episodes and cliffhangers
that's cool I love that how that was his
idea like it sounds like him and
Deborah's idea of how they would handle
like this miniseries rumor that's been
going around and that might be the best
bet especially to distinguish itself and
make it up a new kind of event and maybe
take some of the pressure off of it
being like oh great for our yeah
plus you know if the first episode has
some issues they can only go do more the
executives left the meeting pumped yeah
neither cut was real except then it
almost wasn't mmm the novel coronavirus
struck in Hollywood all but shut like
this is this is what I mean man
rollercoaster memory story it's like
overcoming constant obstacles to have
your dream fulfilled yeah the novel
coronavirus struck in Hollywood all but
shut down in mid-march
debora people thought it won't be
possible to ramp up and then maybe this
should go on the back burner but we said
no this is the right time because our
visual effects houses that rely on so
much are running out of work and so now
is the time to be doing this it also
held that many of those post facilities
had held on to the original assets is
great everyone's rainy day fund is
working out I mean everyone who worked
with Zack Snyder seems like they really
preferred that version oh yeah we want
to come out visual effects people the
cinematographer the cast I'm just
waiting for Joss Whedon to come out and
be like I personally hated everything I
don't know why you know for this to be
going on is also a great time for the
people who are not able to do the work
of needed to you know make some money
this is a great opportunity for them
yeah I mean I I really admire that
aspect to even think of that because you
know there's so much fanfare around it
and there's so much personal stuff tied
to it and so for them to be like yeah
let's give these underappreciated
industry professionals some actual work
to is a solid move snyder also spent
april and may reach nuts of the sizable
cast giving a heads up on the new
development and other services may be
needed first person called ray fisher
who played cyborg
oh i didn't even read this bar he was
like you're kidding me right that's cool
and then he called as Ram Miller yeah
Ezra Miller got so excited right Fischer
was the first one they call he was one
of my favorite parts that movie there is
no schedule going for it at this stage
for the project as talks are now
beginning with post-production houses
also goes HBO max plan it's time to find
the best way to present this version of
Justice League Snyder's at the same time
imposed on army the Dead which has
Christie Elia his zombie thriller for
Netflix that will also debut in 2021
for the Snyder's that
Hansa revisit the movie also brings a
prospect for closure on a project they
were forced to let go this movie was the
culmination of a hero's journey that all
these characters went on and the idea
was always to build them up to be the
heroes people expected them to be that's
cool so going from the dark side and
honestly what from what they've talked
about and said it lines up with the
first trailer that came out from Justice
League which did present a more heroic
tone to it because I like Man of Steel I
like it a lot BBS I mean it's not
denying it we're not big fans I dislike
that but the Justice League I remember
the first trailer that got me really
excited because I did feel more like not
it wasn't like trying to be Marvel but
it seemed like it was going in that
direction the more positive light yeah
at least something you can root for it
yeah if we have more than heroic tone to
it and while the cup will contain the
many elements Zack is teased over time
yes expect Darkseid awesome also relish
adding a fair amount of character
development what's so lovely about this
is that we get to explore these
characters and ways and you're not able
to in a shorter theatrical version that
gives me the most hope for the quality
especially Zack Snyder because any time
he does an extended cut it's always
always better and and like I I honestly
I strongly disliked BVS and partly
because yeah there's just so much that
doesn't get to flow into a
two-and-a-half-hour movie so I think
yeah the the series idea plus that extra
flesh is a terrific concept the ultimate
addition of BBS it's strange because
there's not like 15 to 20 minutes extra
footage but it does make the movie but I
definitely prefer that version that's
and the motives make more sense and it
flows better in that version so I would
say I like The Ultimate Edition version
not a fan of the theatrical version
overall I'll watch it the Snider's know
that the fan power is what led to the
Snyder Cut becoming a reality that's
what was so cool about the stream was
that he had fans come on to celebrate
the announcement with that I don't know
how these fans were selected but they
came on and it was cool clearly this
wouldn't be happening without them he
also credits warned us were living up to
its old reputation as the filmmaker
studio after all that was weird
decisions coming back to it and he adds
this return to the pedigree and to let
my singular vision of my movie be
realized in this format and this length
is
president and a brave move I can't argue
with that man yeah yeah yeah I can't
argue with that
it's weird I remember when they first
like resurrected Family Guy like when TV
shows were doing that yeah for something
like this I've never actually
experienced before her you know well
this is I mean this is 20 million
dollars yeah or 30 maybe more a cut of a
movie that came out just a couple of
years ago or like a few years ago right
if anything I thought this might have
been that Superman to Richard Donner cut
or many years later we get either the
the Jon Schnepp thing with the
documentary or we get the random like oh
we're getting the original cut now and I
thought that's the direction would be
headed but for this to happen so soon
while the fandom and the outpouring of
demand for this is still so strong and
relevance and rising Lee after several
years after we've already had a billion
dollar Aquaman movie yeah it's just Sam
Joker you know this to still be talked
about and for people to still be excited
about the new Batman movie road passes
all working out looks like they're gonna
have to get the original cast back that
Affleck I'm excited for him to properly
finish this out because then Affleck has
had such a strange journey with Batman
and despite my personal opinions on BBS
I still thought Ben Affleck was
incredible this would be a cool return
for him obviously Jason Momoa is been
very supportive about the rest of the
cast is obviously been very supportive
about it that's the breakdown of what to
expect I'm excited for what we're gonna
see here yeah I mean it makes me wonder
like I almost feel like if the
coronavirus hadn't happened this might
not be happening the way it is you know
because also you can bet that part of it
is they're going we can't produce a lot
of new content we have all this footage
here we can make something out of I mean
they're gonna work with what they got
now and then they're gonna go back and
then do the reshoots they need to Ben
Affleck has time to do that training
montage and then really quick the Ruby
Rose situation with her leaving Batwoman
honestly I didn't hop on one you do a
video about it because I haven't watched
the Batwoman show like I've seen Ruby
Rose and the crossovers I saw her first
introduction in the crossovers I mean I
said in a live stream not long ago that
I could feel from the few times I've
seen her in these event episodes and for
trailer two with madwoman I can enjoy
Ruby Rose's Batwoman enough in the like
supporting role if she's part of this in
Samba land she's not the main character
I could enjoy her there I definitely
didn't ever love her portrayal I wasn't
a fan of the idea of how my people were
just hating the crap out of her know
when all that was going on when this was
announced she eventually left Twitter
was weird about this what's what's weird
about this is that there was a lot of
buildup to bat woman bat woman comes out
has its first season they introduced
like this Batman character I think at
the end or something like a person who's
actually the face of Bruce Wayne and we
finally got a face - Bruce Wayne yeah
and it allowed the ratings to go what on
that woman after him like two weeks ago
were some people were saying the ratings
were going down for the show during
quarantine this is bad and then she
leaves the show it's not the first time
a lead has left I mean usually it's for
sometimes it could be more tragic
reasons like I watched Spartacus the
show last year and the actor who plays
Spartacus died in between seasons so
they had to replace him I haven't seen
bad woman so I can't really attest to
how much fans will miss her and I'm
seeing a lot of people who are doing
videos on this who am were one of them
now who haven't seen who don't watch the
show but are talking about it the ones
that I have not really ever heard a kind
word toward and not that I was looking
for you know negative feedback but yeah
of you know Supergirl and Batwoman both
and I feel like that woman Moore has
yeah that backlash on a rival and with
Ruby Rose like I am open to her I mean
like I like her general look and
everything and I've seen her in things
that I've enjoyed her in but I feel like
the casting they're just the way it
strikes me was almost like she's really
big right now you know she's getting a
lot of these bit parts let's just throw
her into something without actually
having her prove you know the amount of
chops and gravitas you need to do to
Center a Batwoman type of story the
press release was the most generic of
press release announcement so it wasn't
worth even breaking it down although she
said there's got to be something
underneath the Hat I just I just think
that the experience and fandom community
it was probably a big driving force that
pushed her away I'm not gonna really
talk about her
performance because I don't I haven't
seen the actual show itself only Center
on the crossovers I didn't find her
portrayal on the crossovers to be as
strong as the other performers like I
said she was fine but for the level of
power that's required to lead one of
these shows I just didn't entreat me
enough to go watch it from what I've
heard and there's only from what I've
heard that a lot of people didn't like
her portrayal that's and I'm sure a big
part of that drove her away and I'm sure
WB heard a lot of this too and was like
we could probably do better with someone
else people probably won't miss her the
book ends video we're on the one hand
you're like look how great fan
involvement can be in the other side
where and it's not necessarily the
entire reason but yeah at least part of
it I have to imagine and comes down to
people or harassing you because they
just don't like what you're doing with
this character or whatever which there's
so many decisions and factors that
figure into that and that is an aspect
of fandom I find very unfortunate yeah I
mean we don't know we we don't know we
don't know the thing is it's like what
you speculate on what most people are
speculating on sounds like one I always
feel like if they release a very generic
statement about something there's
there's just gotta be some kind of harsh
truth underneath that's not being
revealed yeah yeah I feel like this
would be best for Ruby Rose for her
mental health
considering the way fandom has reacted
to her I don't say treating her but
reacted to her there's gotta be a huge
bummer yeah her you know because what an
honor to be cast as babble and then of
course with Warner Brothers they might
they might be cool with it too so the
way they could find someone who pants
might latch on to more I'm sure yeah I'm
sure they'll be fine yeah all right guys
lots of news for today and excited for
the Justice League Snyder Kozak Snyder's
Justice League what do you think about
Ruby Rose leaving race the Ruby Rose cut
of season to subscribe to the rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least patron of the day shout out
Jason Dolan Jason I want to give you a
sincere thank you at least the Dolan cut
I wanted to say dude that not long ago I
got on the phone with you and we talked
for like half hour 40 minutes you've
done so much for both of us
in the amount of time that we've got to
know you I was going through a really
challenging time and there was like some
hard things I was dealing with it a
couple of weeks ago the fact that you
were just there for me and you just took
the time out in the middle of you having
a handle the whole bunch of stuff means
a hell of a lot I made a lot of friends
over to our patreon page you are someone
who is I consider like genuinely a
really great close friend of mine man
I'm very much appreciative towards you
and for everything yeah of like beyond
yes you got a camera you've held this
how many times and many things you
pleasure our patreon page a more
importantly emotional support you have
been incredible in that department
especially in my life and creative
support too absolutely 100%
I really thank you heavily from the
bottom of my heart for everything you've
done for us
and more importantly just being an
incredible friend hope to see you again
soon once this whole pandemic is over
you come to California or we go to
Atlanta meet-and-greet anyway love you
dude
yeah me too group Jason just you
exclusive